Welcome to the Taj,  home to statesman and celebrities for over a century Wow. Remember always here at the Taj
we hope you have a good stay
wheres my little boy?
Let's move!
Chaos has erupted in Mumbai with multiple bombings and armed gunmen rampaging through the city
Look I don't think you understand this being an attack and we're not safe
Switch off the lights, under the tables!
Terrorists have laid siege to the landmark Taj
When as many as a thousand guests and over 500 staff trapped inside
You should try to gather whoever we can. If any of you have families at home. There is no shame in leaving
I have been here 35 years
This is my home
we don't know how many there are; where they are
Local police are simply not trained to deal with attacks of this magnitude
Don't open the door it's them!
Do you have a family? Yes and I hope to stay alive and see them
No ones coming for us
Go down the back stairs and straight out the service exit with the terrorists we all die, we take our chances
I'm scared, we all are
Might we all get through this, we must stick together